Brian Wynn horse joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show fresh off a remarkable
performance by Kevin Durant and the rest
of the Warriors like Iguodala and Steve
Kerr having big Wadala in that game when
he looked like half an egg with a low
that was remarkable stuff last night
Brian here on the show how you doing
Brian
hey rich area I'm doing fine great story
today that you wrote about Durant
joining the Warriors to finally beat
LeBron and now it's LeBrons move what
made you think about that after last
night's game well I mean I've obviously
covered they played 33 times I've
probably been at I don't know 25 of them
and what's always been remarkable about
their matchups is how even they are I
mean and the stats are crazy they
averaged the exact 33 games now so we're
not talking a small sample touch talking
basically half a season they are they
average the exact same amount of points
they average the exact same shooting
percentage they have virtually the same
rebounding but when Durant was in
Oklahoma City he was four and 17 against
LeBron and since Durant wants a Golden
State he's heading to the performances
are not different they're exactly the
same it is all about the circumstances
surrounding them and so basically LeBron
a guy who virtually never gets out
maneuvered maybe in the short run but in
the long run LeBron does a lot of
outmaneuvering
has been outmaneuvered here by Durant
and now you got to wonder what LeBron is
gonna do to try to flip it back or if he
can't flip it back because Durant has
got him here
LeBron owned him for nine years Durant
has flipped it in these last two years
make up a lot of ground so then the
question is is how does LeBron flip the
script
does he stay put and try and bring more
to where he currently is or decides to
go and join another situation and
created a la Miami or or created in a
different spot in a different situation
by joining a young and upcoming team
Brian what do you I don't know I don't
know you could bring on 15 people you
can bring on players you can bring on
executives you can bring on media
members to analyze the situation
as far as where I look there isn't a
perfect scenario any choice of he makes
today I always have to preface that
because the NBA changes every 15 minutes
we just had a placement of executive 15
minutes ago
yeah the NBA changes every 15 minutes
but today I don't see the option that he
has where he doesn't make some sort of
significant compromise whether it's
conference family considerations talent
considerations leaving home staying home
all he has their choices with
significant compromises right now I I
don't know I honestly don't know and he
doesn't either I jump trust me on this
he doesn't know what he's gonna do and
the reason why is because he's just been
focused on basketball I mean none of
none of it really dawns on him in a
quiet moment you know because well we're
already turned the page as a members of
the media I know because it's a no three
hole in which he's in Brian
of course he's thought about it rich but
go go get 50 go get 300 people yes even
even if he sat there and thought about
it every day for the last month if the
situation is not gonna change he has a
whole bunch of options none of them are
great I mean I just I just said last
night I'm saying it jokingly I want to
make that 100% clear I'm joking
got that jo ki ng nice I was like you he
had a call of Durant see what he's doing
in free agency because like I don't see
it I don't see a situation right now
that completely makes this an
instantaneous reversal like Durant
executed two years ago and that's what
he's gonna figure out over the next 3-4
weeks and I agree with you rich that
LeBron Street is he started last night
yep Brian win worst of ESPN joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show so you made
reference to the fact that the Sixers
and Bryan Colangelo are parting ways
your front your colleague woge says it's
going to be termed as a resignation do
you believe it's David Griffin's job
essentially based on everything that the
Sixers need a general manager he's got
experience he's got experience of the
ring he's got experience is winning a
ring with LeBron is that a no-brainer
Bryan not necessarily I think you know I
have a personal Asian ship but David I
think he's really
smart I think he's a really good GM by
the way LeBron doesn't really care who
the general manager is I mean silver on
here's who the players are and David
will be the first to tell you LeBron did
not come to Cleveland because because
David Griffin
LeBron wouldn't go anywhere but David
Griffin got hired in the minor league
team in Minot South Dakota he wouldn't
know what zomick's LeBron I got to do
with David Griffin but I mean David
Griffin is a competent executive who has
who has shown he knows how to build a
champion team around LeBron and that
would make him a pretty good resume spot
for him but I'm just going to say to you
the number one thing for LeBron when it
comes to choosing the next team is
competition to win a championship and
I'm going to tell you that number two
and maybe even one a is going to be
ownership what is his relationship with
the ownership how does he feel about the
ownership how did we feel about the
ownerships commitment when when when the
Brawn came back to Cleveland he did not
meet with Dave's dress he met with Dan
Gilbert when he meets to make a decision
whether it's to stay in Cleveland to go
elsewhere it's going to be with
ownership ownership is incredibly
important general managers and coaches
and players change owners do not change
that is very important to LeBron that's
something that's you know I don't know
on the pie chart whether it's worth 20
percent or 5 percent or 96 percent I I
don't know where it is I know that it
matters and Sixers ownership is and and
and how they approach LeBron when the
time comes is going to be just as
important as who is in that general
manager chair so best you can tell since
we're on the subject here and you know
ownerships not changing which ownership
group do you think best fits LeBron and
vice versa and knowing the landscape as
you do I don't know that's amazing
I don't know rich I mean I know I know
you're asking a fair question I don't
know I just either I don't need your
point is that so the metrics are are
LeBrons and he's figuring out what they
are and until he fits sits face to face
with these people we have no earthly
idea how he's going to think about it my
point is I think it's very easy to jump
to a conclusion
Oh David Griffin and I'm LeBrons going
to come five minutes later
but we want to connect down now Ryan
that's what we do in the business and we
want it so it's so much more complex
than that it's so much more complex than
that
I do think whether it's David great for
anybody else one of the things that
whoever retains LeBron going forward
he's going to have to prove that they
are going to know how to competently
take care of the rest of his
championship window years that's become
very important to him
and you know his family is gonna be
important too you know he's got a 13
year old son I mean this is something
nobody's thinking about just thirteen
year old son I you know I'm not so sure
he's competent a bit to rip him away and
take him to the city he's never been to
before when he's entering high school
without a factory last two free agency
but his son is going to sit with him and
have a discussion about how he feels
again on the pie chart can I put a
percentage on it no I can't but I'm
telling you that's there and you know I
just I just think it's gonna be this is
very difficult to handicap there's gonna
be a whole lot of people out there in
the next few days or a few weeks who are
gonna pound their chest and say they
know what he's gonna do in ways they do
and they may end up being right but they
only be right to say guests right couple
more minutes left with Brian Wynn Horst
here so let's not give short shrift to
the dynastic team that is gonna win
three and four years and look so
terrific and is deep they're deep it's
not just it's not just the Hamptons five
or whatever you want to call them it's
also a coach that is burnishing a Hall
of Fame resume in his own right and some
other guys who are stepping up and and
making big plays I give you the floor on
on the Golden State Warriors and what
you think they mean to the NBA and if
you think it is a good thing what we're
seeing play out with golden you know for
most of the year rich I didn't think
they looked to be that deep Iguodala was
terrible for a lot of the year you know
you Zaza Pachulia became unplayable
Patrick Makau guy that they were really
counting on to be a rotation player had
terrible injury and has not been able to
play Nick Young was a signing that did
not bear fruit there were individual
moments where it looked okay but
generally it did not bear fruit what
they have is they have gamers they hey
you know Shaun Livingston is a game
amongst gamers and Andre with Dallas one
of the most competitive and smartest and
most valuable players to have in a
playoff game I've ever seen
and so they have guys who step up and
then then they have javale mcgee me
javale mcgee has been terrific these
last two games discovered the
laughingstock in the league he was still
gonna be he still laughingstock in
league at times but he put him in the
right position and he executed and so
what makes it you know they're a
championship dynasty team because they
have all-stars but they have really
smart players
and they trust each other and they know
how to handle their business and Steve
Kerr has a tremendous sense he knew that
your veil McGee would would work he put
him in and it worked but I actually
think that they have some upward
mobility I think that they can do a lot
better on spot seven through eight to
ten on their roster and I I actually
believe or not expect them to in the
next year to Brian always enjoy our
chats that's the way I feel like I and
every single one of these conversations
really do and look forward to it more
over the next several weeks
thank you Richard have a good day you
got it that's Brian when were stat win
horst ESPN the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience